qué consiste el acuerdo final que pactó
el el g20 y que han dicho en los
mandatarios hasta el momento sobre las
conclusiones
noches efectivamente las conclusiones
hay que dividirlas en dos porque
recordemos que ayer el tema era la
recuperación económica tras la crisis
sanitaria y la crisis sanitaria vamos a
recordar los compromisos de ayer
rápidamente es ese compromiso de las
naciones de que el próximo año a
mediados del 2022 un 70 por ciento de la
población tenga al menos dos dosis de
vacuna contra el cob y 19 esa creación
de una fuerza de trabajo para evitar las
pandemias y para estar mejor preparados
que incluye además dinero y
transferencia para los países más pobres
para tener por ejemplo las vacunas en
general las donaciones de vacunas y el
trabajo para elaborar vacunas en
conjunto con los países pobres no solos
en conjuntos con los países pobres y es
impuestos de un 15 por ciento a las
multinacionales en los países donde
operan para que los países tengan
recursos justamente para hacer frente a
este tipo de catástrofe y hoy obviamente
el tema ha sido el clima lo que es muy
importante ya que esta noche comienza en
glasgow la cob 26 y las conclusiones han
sido muy importantes las que tú
mencionabas no es cierto
a reconocer que el aumento de las
temperaturas del planeta no puede pasar
del 15 grados es más ambicioso que el
acuerdo del clima de parís sabemos que
si se pasa a ese aumento habría
catástrofes naturales en nuestro planeta
muy importante es también la eliminación
de los subsidios a las centrales
termoeléctricas al carbón a nivel
internacional ahí queda sobre todo la
duda y la decepción de muchas personas
porque recordemos que china tiene mil
millones de centrales de termoeléctricas
más de la mitad de las centrales de todo
el planeta y es un país que por ahora no
se manifestó en hacer una transferencia
o una transición nada como se dice
energética en ese sentido y también ese
fondo económico de 100 mil millones de
euros que ya estaba en las previas cop
pero ya hacer lo concreto y efectivo
para ayudar a los países pobres a la
transición en general quienes hablaron
el primer ministro británico por el
consell que se mostró muy optimista
aunque dijo obviamente que
él reconoció lo que son los aportes del
reino unido- como también lo hizo luego
el presidente manuel macrón que dijo
cuáles habían sido los aportes concretos
de francia pero en general ellos
reconocen que hay un camino largo y
difícil pero están todos contentos con
este reconocimiento internacional del
control de las temperaturas de la
limitación de las temperaturas a 1,5
grados celsius si a propósito de la
crisis climática de la que usted nos
hablaba el primer ministro de italia
mario draghi fue bastante optimista en
el discurso de cierre a pesar de que
antonio guterres el secretario general
de la onu advirtió que no se logró lo
suficiente que fue lo que dijo el
mandatario italiano
si él fue optimista justamente porque
hasta ahora nunca en un documento ni del
g20 ni de la cob todos los países al
menos los más contaminantes habían
reconocido la necesidad de mantener las
temperaturas en 1,5 grados celsio el
aumento de las temperaturas con respecto
a la era preindustrial por lo tanto él
dijo hoy estamos todos de acuerdo el
desafío grande pero al menos estamos
todos unidos en este en este desafío
entonces eso es lo más importante que
destaco draghi y él decía justamente que
los ecologistas dicen que nosotros los
políticos siempre hacemos blah blah blah
que hablamos de manera vacía pues esta
vez él dijo yo siento de manera muy
emocionada además que nuestras palabras
han cobrado sustancia o sea que son
palabras más concretas y por lo tanto
ahora es la hora de actuar dijo el por
qué seremos juzgados por nuestras
acciones en general mario draghi ha
mostrado una personalidad del líder
europeo en momentos en que los grandes
líderes es decir macro y angela merkel
por una parte en el que se va y makro a
asumir la presidencia de la unión
europea el próximo año y por lo tanto
quizás él va a pasar a ocupar un lugar
muy importante del unión europea